and um what we'll do today is uh go
through brief introductions of each
panelist and then uh kind of go through
a series of questions hopefully we'll
have a live uh good back and forth and
we'll have a Q&A from the audience for
the last 10 15 minutes so without
further Ado why don't we start from uh
fun on my left so we do our self
introduction all right um I um
I'm with JP Morgan I run the Masson
banking business uh for JP Morgan in uh
China um I'm here to uh
to you know to listen to The Experience
the venture capitalist about what they
want to invest and we obviously follow
them to uh make sure the company they
invested will grew well and eventually
we'll take them to the capital markets
so that's what we do so I'm service
provider to the entrepreneurs and to the
venture
capitalist that's all uh hi my name is
Haney nada I am a venture capitalist uh
based here in Meno Park but I spend
quite a bit of time in China we actually
have U four funds under management about
a billion
six uh in US dollar equivalent um our
latest fund is a $600 million $625
million group of funds one is 100
million is R&B the rest are US Dollars
uh we've been doing business in China
since 2000 we have an office in Shanghai
a small office in
Beijing uh had a good track record a
good run good run so far we've invested
in uh every company that uh see
companies that I can think of we
invested in Alibaba early early in its
life um we invested in tudo early it's
life we invested in uh tunar which I
think you guys heard a little bit about
today we've got a good uh pedigree of
track records co-invested with many of
these guys and some great
companies uh it's good to be here I'm a
St for alum did my undergrad in uh what
is not MSE back then it was industrial
engineering um I ran the Beijing office
for Ching Venture Partners we have uh
three funds all USD funds and two RB
funds all of them were started since
2006 it's a total of about a billion
dollar us and a billion R&B we have uh
70 plus profoto companies all in China
um of which half are in uh consumer
interet Group which are co-run with
another colleague some of the Prof
companies you may heard of include um
van
PPS
co-invest together so we co-invest with
a lot of super Angels uh we're very
close to Jason from tensen and obviously
leging from kingsoft so he has been a
good run and it's good to be back here
on campus and share what we have seen
and learn from our of you as
well okay uh hi my name is Shing uh
because of my name in China people call
me comr
shoing shoing and uh uh I was a CO of NE
rental education uh China's largest
education company uh in English training
and Tesla coaching last year alone we
trained uh 3.5 million students that's
in last year alone and uh since our
successful IPO in 2006 I began to do uh
anual investment since then we have
invested about
150 cases uh lots of them and and I
always told people my successful rate is
100% because I forgot all the failed
ones I never remember them and since
last year uh we partnered with s China
uh formed the $30 million uh Angel fund
spe specialized in Angel investment so
uh we want to become China's best angel
and to help uh young entrepreneurs to uh
you know grow their dreams and our team
uh is uh maybe China's most uh
Diversified globalized team our general
manager is uh American Chinese American
uh Stanford alarm our portfolio
portfolio manager is a parado native
also a Stanford alarm uh T Cox she's
sitting there and uh you know uh I am a
chinesee bilingual obviously uh so we
want to come here want to you know
extend our enjoy investment and uh you
know uh startup experience to the local
uh entrepreneurs Chinese community and
the local community so you know become a
truly real uh Global Angel that's why
we're here I want to make one comment on
c shaing um career for those of you who
are here for the lunch presentation by
John hban he said he was a failed
musician
then he went into politics and shaing is
a failed musician that went to business
and made much bigger than than Dr
hansman so shaing did his undergraduated
m music theory but went into education
and now he's the educator for all the uh
andreid investors and and startup or
would be startups actually I'm a
although I failed a musician but I very
successful music teacher right I told in
P University and one of my students at
that time was the worst student was Ying
home who let start in a new orental so I
became a now I you know anyway so it's
good to study music well you know uh in
English there's a uh saying those who
can do and those who can't teach and uh
it's very uh in some ways it's a very
similar um VC relationship between
entrepreneurs and VCS as well and
ambassadors that's correct ambassad
politicians yes okay um this panel is
about investment Outlook uh just to give
audience a little bit of background I
think the largest topic an investment
outlook for China has been really The
Slowdown that people have been talking
about um and particularly in the um
Venture side of the world um you know
there's been really three components of
why things have slowed down one is
certainly U many of the accounting
frauds that occurred in China U making
investors kind of lose confidence in the
public market you also have kind of the
overall economics macroeconomic slowdown
and thirdly very specific to how
startups are structured you know the
whole Alibaba Yahoo viie um controversy
has really um become the Third Leg of
why the whole slowdown in the Venture
industry in China has occurred having
said that the economy is still growing
at 7 and a half percent per year which
is still uh very very large um growth
rate and so I'd love to ask the panelist
about you know what are their opinions
on so far have they felt the Slowdown uh
whether they think it's temporary and uh
you know the Everlasting question of
when do you think the IPO window would
open up the last Company from China
that's really gone public on the US
market is Vip Shop we were very
fortunate to be involved with that uh
and it's probably one of the few stocks
that's gone public in the recent years
that where the public pric is above the
IPO price so um I think things are
healing but yet you know it's very
interesting to see the IPO Windows still
closed so you know any if any other
panelists want to take this um of course
we have the investment banker who who
knows all about the pipeline here
so okay I will go first um yes we do
have a very healthy pipeline of
companies that want to go public either
in the US or in Hong Kong but uh on the
investor side the public portfolio
investor side uh they are uh taking a a
cautious uh view on where they put their
beted on where they're going to invest
uh for many reasons one I guess David
you mentioned that there's overall
overhanging view that uh the economy is
slowing down uh but after all if you
look at horizontally 7.5% probably still
the uh most significant growth a growing
economy in the world in terms of um uh
growth rate and the uh and it by the way
it is
growing um on a much bigger base if you
look at the GDP of 2000 year 2000s and
the GDP today the GDP has quad doubled
so a
7.5% growth today is it's about 30%
growth um 10 years ago um uh given the
uh difference base uh of GDP so from
that point of view um I would I would be
uh of the view that um uh the consumer
business will continue continue to grow
because the disposable income are
increasing the the universe of your
target client base are
increasing um on the investor side I got
to believe that they will come back to
the table at some point when the
valuation is um is attractive or they
believe the valuation is becoming more
attractive because they are uh they are
managing other people's money they need
to make sure the money
is in play and and most recently we are
seeing um investors putting their money
back into the game uh we are able to
raise money for um a lot of good
companies whether in the clean tech
business whether in the financial
services business uh in the uh real even
in the real estate investment business
so investors are coming back when they
see good value so the door will not be
shut forever so for those of you who are
in my pipeline uh stay tuned the market
will be back H and horaney do you and
anybody in the panel uh so um all these
guys are pointing to me because they
don't want to answer the question first
because they're they're afraid to give
you the bad news so I I think it largely
depends on your point of view if your
point of view is you're sitting as
Venture investor with a very large
portfolio and you're seeing the
valuations get wiped off the face of the
planet um you're in pretty Dire Straits
I think um in the time of the market
where valuations were extremely high I'd
say about a year and a half ago two
years ago where it was a party it was a
party and there were drugs being passed
out there was alcohol being served and
valuations were stupidly High uh and you
invested at that time I think you're
feeling a lot of pain today big hangover
um and frankly many of the companies
that we were that people invested in
whether it was in e-commerce sector the
clean teex sector that require a lot of
capital to be sustained I think those a
lot of those are in trouble I would fair
to say that the average valuation in
that sector is down north of
90% uh so if you're at a billion dollar
valuation a year or a year and a half
ago you're trying to raise money today
you'd be lucky to get $100 million
valuation that's the reality what's
happening and what's happened in China
in certain parts of the market
segment um at the same time that period
was a fantastic time to take comp
companies public we had 10 IPOs in our
portfolio in the last two years uh six
were domestic in the US uh NYC NASDAQ uh
and then four in the Shanghai stock
exchange so we've had a good run and
many of those companies I'd say more
than 75% of those companies are above
the IPO price and they're doing quite
well um and those companies have strong
governance have a great operating
leverage in their business and they're
taking market share away from the weaker
competitor private comp competitors
today um uh so that when you're in the
party mood our our attitude is to sell
rather than Buy in the last six months
it's been a very different Market it's
been a buyer market so if you take a
look at our pipeline our pipeline is
full of very interesting attractively
priced private companies and it's great
place we just raised our fourth fund
it's a great place to be we have a bunch
of fresh Capital going after a market
where everybody's scared to invest um
that that's how you make a lot of money
in this business so it really depends on
your point of view as a point of view of
a new fund looking for investment it's a
great time to be alive if you're an
existing fund that has a lot of money
out at high valuations it's a pretty
crappy time to be
out um from my perspective you know in
preparation of this um panel um I went
through some of the numbers that we
prepared at our last annual meeting at
the end of last year just for comparison
um about $30 billion us have been
invested into um BCB investments in
China that's both R&B and
USD uh if you look at assuming that
that's roughly 15% ownership in the
companies are in that's roughly $200
billion of Entry price um you look at
the the IPO proceeds that been raised um
in the um in the US and China That's
roughly $140 billion US half us h Kong
elsewhere half in China if you assume
that the U 30 billion number of going to
vent Investments 80% are in the um um
the uh um uh offshore investment vehicle
that's 24 billion 15% that's uh roughly
160 billion and then if you take that um
and assume that the IPO proceeds the one
I went offshore 70 billion is roughly
25% of the company 280 million so you're
comparing um 280
billion as the uh IPO valuation of these
companies offshore listing versus the
about 160 billion going into this um
cost base going in you have a roughly
1.7x so for the whole industry it's not
bad that's the good news the bad news is
that these stocks are not as liquid as
we will hope our our we have about 10
exits five our IPOs five our Tre sales
but if you look at the the IPOs you want
to get out of this position now it's
definitely not a good time and for some
of the TR sale we were fortunate to get
out of them would do that right after
when dong and the yuku went public and M
2010 so at that point it was a good time
to sell some and we did I think the
lesson that I learned as a v capitalist
for last 78 years in China is that when
the timing is good take some money off
the table really take some money off the
table there were a lot of IPOs that were
done price would been going up and VCS
are in and they think that price will
always go up and just don't get out and
I think it takes a lot of discipline and
some of the companies are mine and I
love them and it's my partner who says H
you should sell really you should sell
and it's always easy to tell someone
else to sell their favorite Investments
that that you do do that but I think
that's what a partnership is for um but
since end of 2011 to now boy uh Park
valuation have gone down quite a bit
private Market valuation haven't gone
down as fast the good companies that we
see today still ask for okay maybe 20%
discount from the height the of the
market but still valuations don't not
cheap serious B we're seeing in China is
still being done at about 50 to 60
million pre series a the good one still
doing being done at about 20 million pre
50 million pre at best um and the CRC
some of it is going above above 100
million and that's a scary number in
this market so there are few really
interesting teams and Deals going out
lots of money is still chasing them um
it's China is raising a you know 10
billion do of funds being raised
practically every year so still too much
money chasing a few interesting deals
and the interesting deals are not really
necessarily good deals they is
interesting because you do have BYU
10cent and Ali out there the three
mountains and seen a half a mountain
there and each you have to figure out
how is my company going to work with
every at least one of them or two of
them so that they can grow big and when
they grow big you got to figure out how
to create exit market so that there will
be competition to buy this company
you'll get valuation that both
entrepreneurs and VCS want if we're
lucky one of them big guys will invest
like with you know hopefully like tunar
and that chinar go public on its own
that would be the ideal scenario so
definitely doing V investment in China
is getting harder and
harder uh once I was asked the same
question uh you know for the IPO Winters
I said the winter for VC and PE is the
spring for Angels because uh you know uh
as a angel investment that we have only
little money so we cannot compete uh
against those VC guys right we don't
want to compete so yeah during the past
we want to work with you during the past
few years we saw many VCS send cases to
us otherwise they would invest right in
May last year 2011 j.com went IPO so at
that time I was telling myself you know
we would use all the you know profits to
reinvest so you know IP of course you
know is good because you know those
companies when they have more money then
they can you know uh keep investing
investing but for now it's a good time
for Ango investment uh you know we we
saw a few down runs although we want to
give them more money but uh the market
you know is there so we just uh uh you
know give them money and with some
crocodiles
tears David your what are you seeing in
the
market
um I think the uh what's interesting is
you know Tech Cycles must go
in um in Cycles uh By Nature and it's is
usually a 10year cycle um and U you know
as evidenced you know the last internet
bubble was 99 2000 and you know 10 12
years later you see kind of the social
networking Facebook wave and I think in
China each cycle has been really
compressed into about four or five years
um but I think what what you're seeing
now is definitely a down cycle um in
particularly um there's just too much
money out there it's kind of like in the
US in 2002 2003 there was this you know
Wonderful word in the VC industry called
overhang which was just more money being
raised than you know the demand calls
for in the US it's now around um it's
quite balanced in terms of demand and
Supply in China's case as Hans was
saying um was alluding to the money
available in China um and too many funds
just raiseed too much money compared to
what the true real demand and what the
requirements are and so this you know
what um Haney was saying about series a
series B you know prices as well as what
Hans was saying it's it's still good for
entrepreneurs because there's too much
money supply and so it' be interesting
can if the China's 45e cycle
continues you know to hang in there for
3 four years is great right
if it goes to a normalized 10year tech
cycle like the rest of the world it
could be a world of hurt in about 2
three years um so that's that's kind of
the perspective that um I hold although
I think you know Miss um what Zuul was
saying is absolutely right I think the
seed capital is getting much more active
um than five years ago I think the US
kind of started that Trend two three
years ago and I think in China it's it's
definitely exploding in terms of a in
terms of a trend um now let me shift
over it when the IPO line is is tied up
in the US what happens is the m&a gets
quite active um you know large companies
today I mean look at Apple I mean they
have more money than God I think now um
in the bank account close uh close right
and and it's great time for m&a
activities um but in China China
traditionally m& has not been a a a
normal vehicle uh for for exits do you
see that changing and you know if it
does happen you know in what form do you
think it'll come in do you think it's
the 2030 million dollar takeouts that
you know Google did two three years ago
or do you think there'll be big you know
whe the big mountains as um um one of
the panels alluded to are going to start
moving fairly quickly over the next year
or two any any views on
that okay I'll go uh
first um m&a has not been as an exit has
not been that active in China of the
past um uh 10 years as I can see um
occasionally there trade sales um but
there is a there is a increase there is
a trend of increasing uh uh of uh trade
sales than IPOs obviously it's a
function of the of the uh IPO Market
itself but also I think it's also
function of the uh entrepreneurs
mentality uh uh more and more
entrepreneurs are willing to uh uh to to
to exess through the uh trade cell uh
we've seen good uh cases in the in in
the new sectors in the uh education
space in the uh V uh space in the uh
internet um mobile internet gaming uh
space and so forth because um people
just see there's no way to hope the
market can have more than three big
players so for the for the for the
second tier players they're more than
willing to uh exit in that way having
said there is another uh Trend that is
going on in a bigger way that is the
taking
private uh it is less of a traditional
m&a uh business but it it's a good way
for the VCS to put money into work uh
because um a you know supposedly a good
uh high quality business the public
markets do not appreciate the value the
growth potential so the founders and the
initial uh seed run investors and all
early stage investors they get together
uh they buy the business back uh we have
done
good uh buyback uh
businesses uh with Shanda uh we're doing
uh that with uh focused media uh and a
few many a few others in the
pharmaceutical space and in in in other
space so do you think they're doing that
because in the long run they want to go
public again maybe not in the US this
time but maybe in the domestic or other
markets obviously uh you know the the
participating venture capitalist and and
and the entrepreneur itself have a
vision of doing the the IPO again a few
years later back in Asia not in the US
or they may very well do IP in the US
when they see the valuation is at the
reasonable level um
so you know and also there are
entrepreneurs that want to take the
company private because they see in that
way it's easier for them to do m& so are
setting a stage for bigger m&a going
forward that would be my
observation any comment from that end um
I I one day in the entrepreneur
Gathering somebody were accusing tent uh
not too you know uh good to
entrepreneurs always they saw a good
project they will do their own and kill
them uh then the co-founder of tent T he
said uh last year there spent a lot of
money by companies uh because of after
the 3Q War they were forced you know to
do something better uh as for new rental
since our IPO once our PE ratio was 90
uh that high and the the uh market cap
was five billion but we never did any
real anate so many good company was just
missed the reason is uh Chinese
companies IPO companies that don't have
that kind of a tradition uh that kind of
sence so they are learning whether we
forced or taught or you know uh with
some good examples so I heard recently
uh new R are setting a fund you know for
M you know to buy growing companies so I
think that will
come so we've we've uh ggv has been
involved just re recently with three
pretty significant um m&a transac
actions uh uh tudo Yoku um now is on the
board for tudo for a number of years and
that deal actually started in uh in in
Earnest in 2006 so it's taken a long
time for it to to to actually happen um
the other one was the uh recent
Strategic investment by Buu into chunar
and that was also a partial uh almost
Force liquidity on part of the
shareholders um and then also just most
recently we announced uh isoft is in uh
conversations to acquire merge with uh
Vance info um all those deals uh were
very significant from an m&a perspective
in China and all those deals were very
very different um you know I've been in
the business for 20 two years and I've
done m&a both on in US companies
International companies and now in China
and the
cultural nuances of doing m&a in China
the amount of
conversations um are incredible um in
China the L the longest and the largest
debate and negotiation in one of those
transactions was actually about the name
it wasn't about the
price the price took literally 30
seconds to agree to and it took over two
hours to agree on a name and spe
especially where the hyphen is going to
go um so it was pretty ridiculous
obviously from a westerners
perspective um so I think you're going
to see more m&a in China um and I think
you're going to see more strategic mmaa
in China I don't count anything above or
below $100 million of Strategic
investment I think more of like an AC
ACU
high so for me to make money it's got to
be a pretty significant outcome it's got
to be almost $300 million more outcome
and there's not a lot of those I think
for the seed stage you're going to see
lots of small 10 15 million maybe
hundred million doar acquisitions that
they can make great money at for for me
as a VC who's you know putting out5 to
$25 million I I need to see $300 million
plus 7A and I think you're going to see
in China as the liquidity options
evaporate the emperor mentality of a lot
of the smaller companies going to go
away and I think you'll see them much
more open to m&a at the same time folks
like tenens Cent who say I want to be in
that
market and have a harder time getting
that market they usually try a product
out first and it fails and they say you
know well they're doing it better
than than we are how come they're doing
it better than we are and they have to
fail a couple times before they'll say
you know what let's just buy it and so
that'll take some time I mean China
technology Market is fairly new as
someone said earlier so it'll take some
time for the m&a market to really heat
up in China but right now it's very very
difficult to rely on as an exit strategy
yeah I definitely think I think the the
the
traditional um particularly technology
CEOs in China have a Emperor mentality
and it's really difficult ult for them
to you know submit to another name and I
think Haney's example of where the
hyphen goes is a classic example a
billion doll exit is not a failure
that's a billion
dollars it's a lot of money on the uh
demand side for m&as uh F mentioned
earlier that Chinese companies don't
like to pay for Acquisitions um what has
changed in the last uh uh one year is
that a competition amongst the list of
company have become a lot more fearce uh
chiu and um tensen chiu and Buu chiu and
shiai you see common them here there the
couple people who are troublemakers or
or agitators getting getting the the the
the the battles amongst the the big boys
um heat up and as as a result the um uh
the big boys are more likely to acquire
smaller companies to help them in a
battle against another big boy and as
more of that happen you will definitely
see more m&a over the last 10 years 23
billion dollars in terms of exit value
have been created through m&a but most
last you have come through the Asia
Market with high you know with high PE
as currency stock currency rather than
cash hopefully um that will change in
the next 5 to 10
years if I could shift the conversation
a little bit on the future outlook in
terms of not the financial side but more
about uh Innovation I think
um you know China's always been accused
of um producing me too companies um you
know the Google of China the Facebook of
China the Yahoo of China um and you know
it's it was inevitable in the sense that
the internet curve was definitely behind
the US and I think with the new mobile
the rise of mobile Revolution uh really
hitting hitting the market um you know
with Vigor I think there's a little bit
of um a sense that hey maybe some
Innovation might come out what are some
of the areas that you know each of you
kind of think that would do quite well
over the next three four five years
areas of investment and if there are any
areas where China could actually be
equal or slightly ahead of the rest of
the world and I'd love to you know um
hear about your
views uh um I think I have been thinking
about e-learning uh in 2000 year 2000
Legend group not n level right uh formed
the joint venture with NE rental and uh
we want to do online education so that
that Venture is been there but not doing
very well uh since last year we saw many
we saw sudden increase in revenues from
new rental online education uh some
teachers they used to work 300 days
you know make
300,000 uh remb uh now they may just
teach one week online then you know
every year all the year they sit home uh
receiving money so online education is
really quickly growing so we see this
area maybe uh hopeful uh to you know uh
catch up because China's education is
highly regulated uh everybody complains
about it about that so online education
you know poses opportunity for that when
we saw uh since last year uh in the US
online education particular for college
education become very booming last year
we we saw Stanford uh offered Cera uh so
we wanted to you know uh do you know
work something with them we have not you
know booked appointment with them yet if
someone knows them you know uh give us a
referral we will will give you a good
gift uh so anyway online education uh in
China I think will become the uh you
know next big thing that's what we are
uh focusing on I want to give two very
specific examples of innovation in China
that we actually used and imported back
here to the US uh in one case we did it
successfully uh we saw the free-to-play
inapp purchase Market very early in 200
2003 and having the monetization effect
of media so this is in in this case
gaming moved from a subscription based
service to a free-to-play based service
that did not exist in the US it is now
everywhere in the US we actually
imported it first to a company called
turbine which uh we sold to uh uh Time
Warner uh implement this in one of their
games Dungeons and Dragons we've seen
literally in the first weekend that we
launched it they tripled revenue from
what the Run rate was before so it was
an incredible thing that we imported
directly the other important aspect is
there is a lot of technical Innovation
that's happening in China one of our
portfolio company and some of you may
know it a company called YY or for also
known as danan makes a uh communication
platform inside China for voice
chat and we invested in that company
fairly early on in this life cycle and
what danan does allows people to
communicate over the internet using
voice but they do it uh in Mass so you
can have a single room and you can have
100 people in that room speak and you
can hear everybody and you can have
hierarchical order and it was actually
great for gaming so people used it to
play Counterstrike but we didn't see is
how that continued to innovate and now
is today these guys can handle hundreds
of millions of people actually tens of
millions of people concurrently there's
not a single us company that can do that
not a single international company that
can handle tens of millions of users
concurrently using voice
chat and now the in a model has
innovated even beyond that it's no
longer Gamers actually it's a smaller
part of their business the bigger part
of their business is everything else
karaoke online language lessons poetry
readings Etc social setting up rooms uh
I had heard that there was a professor
uh English Professor or teacher uh that
went and meet met people at Starbucks
took 10 R&B from each of the people and
then gave them the access to the
passwort to his room those models don't
exist in the US those models and that
technology frankly only exists in China
and there's many US companies now that
are trying to copy y why here so um you
see a lot of innovation but you have to
look a little bit more myopically at at
where it is and where it's happening and
what's being imported in China so one
one of the things that we do at ggv is
we try to take the best learnings from
the US and Export them to China and we
try to import the best learnings from
China import them to our us and really
have a much better portfolio and help
our portfolio companies I think you got
to have that I think otherwise you know
the colonial mentality is going to
continue to exist on the part of us VCS
but but let's say If the ratio is 9
to1 UM in terms of you know but in the
US we've been doing this for 30 years in
China it's eight years nine years 10
years no but five years out what do you
think that ratio would
be uh 045
to1 I think from a St point of um what
just to add on what hany said the
freemum model is something that has been
proven in China across multiple segments
of Internet sector although I think if
if there were Korean companies here they
would say they are the first to come up
with a Freeman model and China copied it
so just just for the record I think
China took to the next level so that in
every segment within internet you see
fremium the reason is simple because the
easiest way to compete is raise money
from VC and drive down the price tau is
the first one in China that show Freeman
model works it's the only Ecom
e-commerce company in the world and hone
by anybody else only comes in world that
makes money on advertising and on um
down the road you know Ali pave through
Nona platforms um when it's free people
use it and once it's free you figure out
how to monetize it that's the chu has
done that um tal has done that um B has
done that so the the all the it happens
so often that when we go into an
investment we trying to figure out okay
you're charging money today but what if
it's free then what you going to do and
if you don't do that going in the
investment ain't going to ain't going to
do well um so that that that's one thing
the second thing is that we'll also see
that some of the um um Smart Companies
are leveraging social media to really
Market to lower the user acquisition
cost down so that's another way of
trying trying to um uh beat the odds
with investor in xiaomi xiaomi Shi you
can argue that they try to clone uh
iPhone or clone uh clone Android Google
phone but at the same time they figure
out a way to sell the over sign we at
very low cost um and once you can sell
phones via the Internet you don't have
to pay Distributors you have to share
Revenue with the carriers um so that
your sales cost is is channel cost is
also low so as a result shami can be
profitable even the gross margin doesn't
need to be that high so from that
standpoint it's a micro Innovation it's
not as big as what is in the US but at
this point we're happy to go along for
the right let me tell you another Trend
that we're actually seeing right now in
China that we're trying to figure out
how to replicate it here in the US
monetization of apps is 80% iOS 20%
Android even though Android's got a
bigger market share in China it's
exactly the opposite Android is actually
doing much better in terms of
monetization than its iPhone
counterpart why that's something we're
really looking at because they're doing
it they're doing something right in
China on the Android side in the US it's
not yeah of course one of the reasons is
you know iPhones in China cost $1,000
each um finally the prices are coming
down also there's no iTunes uh store nor
Google Play Store so now can you imagine
buying an and a generic Android phone
and there is no you know localized
Google Play Store um and so they're now
indigenous
domestic um app stores like w Doja and
of course you know all the other big
mountains are all crowding in right um
but it's a very interesting you know
phenomenon and I I think I think China
would have an interesting EP Discovery
Market because I think the Innovation on
in the US is just so dominated by Google
and apple that um I think by having
eight nine players try to figure out how
to really hit the cut consumers cord is
going to be a very interesting Market
there about 150 million smartphones in
China now uh iPhone is a big chunk of it
if not 50% but over the next one year in
one year alone sub 1,000 rem B um
Android based phone will come out in one
year 200
million you can get a um Android
pad and pro the electronic um
cities in China for about 50 bucks now
and so it it's it's going to be a very
interesting Market we launched um uh DCM
launched an Android fund last year and
um it it is incredible um to see the
activities in China uh particularly
around Android um and uh it'll be
interesting because uh you know history
just might repeat itself particularly
around apple and uh China may be the
Catalyst for that I just want to make a
quick comment um observation uh to
answer your question about the
Innovation and um and and how to make
money um I I look at it differently
about Innovation and the me too
technology if you look in the past 10
years uh where are where were the most
money made in the technology Ventures
and where were the biggest trap of the
technology Ventures
all the big all the ones that made big
are in the consumer space they target
individual
customers the ones that destroyed most
of the Venture Capital
Money public invested money were the one
that Target Enterprise
sector uh the enterprise software space
the uh semiconductor design business
which were bu big business in this place
in this country that destroy a lot of
money in China why because the sales
process the certification process were
just you know enormous in China so that
killed a lot of startup companies so if
you want to make if you have if you have
a unique technology and you want to make
it big find the angle that to apply your
technology to the consum consumers
absolutely don't find the angle to sell
to the Enterprises to the China China
Telecom to the China Unicom they're
going to squeeze to the bone of your
business so that is why you see a lot of
me to technology that made a big uh
business in China because they don't
need to do anything they just move the
business model to China turn that into
Chinese they can immediately have 200
million customers they don't need to
worry about whether this
you this comp this customer will squeeze
them because there are enough Customs
out there the universe is big enough to
make the business a valid business model
that is why you see the me to uh from
from uh recruiting to chatting to you
know internet gaming they're all
consumer targeted
businesses so if you are a hardcore
technology you want to make your name in
the Technology Innovation go to the
Enterprise business because that's where
you will get a lot of the government
support you will get some of the uh uh
more dedicated venture capitalist who
still try want to to support and try out
and you can make you can make a big name
in the technology space companies like
Huawei companies like ZTE they I think
both are in the worldwide top five
in terms of number of patents registered
every year so they are big in in
Technology Innovation um although they
are not necessarily making as much money
as 10 cents are doing these days so
that's my observation yeah and and I I
would pretty much agree with that you
know the US VC industry was more or less
B2B first then you have the b2c wave in
China it might fold you know unfold the
other way we certainly come a long way I
mean in the mid to late 990s is when
many of these companies came about in
the first generation and I still
remember in late 90s you know my
co-founder I think he's uh he might be
sitting in the room here but you know it
was not a popular thing to invest in um
China because internet was just too nent
and nobody really knew how things were
going to unfold so it's um it's great to
see that the excitement is still there
and um even after all these years it's
still quite exciting on that note
um we'll take some and field some
questions from the
audience run
run hi um uh I'm Thomas from GSB I have
a question about uh for the investors
what are the unconventional way or the
rules you use in your daily investment
um activities some people say they use
like uh in every investment they they
they relate to Poker so they want to
make the best bad in each of the round
so what what are the other
unconventional
ways what is a conventional
way really you look at the market you
look at a
team and you do the do diligence I mean
that's in my mind probably the
convention ways okay uh let me answer
your question in anual investment
because we don't have anything to audit
on uh to do due diligence so we just
look at the people the you know uh the
team so that's it we we we can't see any
numbers and you know uh track uh lines
so just uh I I think that's the uh
actually it's very uh conventional way
uh just to see people so when they begin
to talk about their business model their
technology you know we we just uh uh
kind of try to ignore because technology
we can't understand at all
anyway and for phys model you will
change for sure in know way you do it so
uh in Ang investment anyway uh people
comes first that's the most important
thing although everybody says that even
in PE they say we invest in people but
it's actually hard you really stick to
this uh principle uh you know sometimes
the company may not good the model may
be bad uh you know model me makes no
sense but when you see this guy you know
has a fire in his eyes has a
determination in his heart you can feel
the heat you from his body language then
we will buy his story although we don't
believe in
that um okay one actually one of the
best uh uh uh project we had we have is
from Stanford alni uh you know uh justb
uh MBA uh he he had a model you know
coming to Beijing he talked to many
investors you know nobody everybody told
him you know your model will not work
all of them are right but they come to
me told me the story the model I really
didn't understand what's
that so I gave him money they half years
later he failed as
scheduled but he because they are smart
you know they are they have the true
entrepreneur spirit so they shifted
pivoted their model now they become
China's number one Cosmetics J yeah jimy
Cosmetics online you know business so
you know just show your heart show your
spirit so we we let the uh the Angels do
that from their uh bets we see which one
have tracked well we don't need to go in
when there's Revenue but we want to see
a product that has users attention user
like it user sickness and from that
we're willing to assume the business
model risk and the uh the people risk
that's somewhat conventional though come
on I I say it's unconventional but it
still took guts to make investment when
just four people in the business plan
and we did that in xiaomi talking about
unconventional investment uh Style again
I comment on shing's Style
um in in one case where I saw a business
plan a front of uh young kids I thought
that was a very interesting business
plan so I I kicked that to shoping I
sent to him and he was traveling in
Europe he said he sent me an email back
say I'm traveling in Europe I'll call
these kids when I'm back so after a few
weeks I haven't heard from him so I sent
him another email I say have you met
them and and and then one evening
midnight I got a call from shopping say
F tell me who are these kids why are you
so admin about me seeing them I said no
just because they they are very very
enthusiastic and they're very dedicated
so I want you to see them so I know
that's his style he look at people uh
not the business plan
so if it was I would
invest go ahead next question I'm
danalis with blue seed erston Yang
reported that in 2010 the total amount
of venture capital invested in US was 7
billion while in China it was only 0.7
billion and uh on the other hand
companies such as Skype benefited from
having offices in um in here in paloalto
Skype was bought by eBay in 2005 I was
wondering what would Chinese investors
think about the idea of bringing their
portfolio companies to Silicon Valley to
increase their valuation by staying here
temporarily let's say
I don't think you by just BR merely
bringing an office and opening up an
office here you increase your valuation
um and it really I mean and there's some
companies that have actually done some
Chinese companies that have done that
open offices Business Development
Offices here but really I think the
biggest thing is that you got to have a
commitment to expanding this and using
this as a Marketplace for your products
and services to really understand in the
market I just having an office here
won't necessarily increase your
valuation I'm me locating here more
permanently not just having a simple
office integrating in the Silicon Valley
Market I do see um in fact yesterday
when after I land um I went straet to
visit a incubator uh the the they are
from the incubator is set up by Chinese
investors they set up office in Silicon
Valley they are incubating companies
startup companies in Silicon Valley that
going back to China they're also
incubating Chinese companies who wants
to expand the business in in in in in in
us so I think that is a very interesting
business model I would encourage you to
to look at them I I think for European
companies to come to Silicon Valley it
makes sense right because it's a bigger
this us is a bigger Market but depending
on your business model you know we have
China that say almost double the number
of Internet users and you know uh the
income is rising ing you really have to
think about whether you want to go to a
smaller Market um if the you know per
per revenue of the users is not all that
high although I think the trend of you
know companies like 10 cents buying you
know companies in the US and trying to
do more activities you know is Shifting
but I think from from coming from China
it's a completely different perspective
than I think coming from like Europe or
Japan to the Silicon Valley next
question
I thank you for sharing us your outlooks
and for the investment I think
investment is all about investing the
value but also take the risk of
following that value and uh Professor
Mark Jeffrey uh Northwest University
Professor wrote a book about data
driving marketing and in his book he was
an opinion that he said if something you
can measure you can control it and also
last May McKenzie released a report and
uh they informed us we are embracing the
time of big data and actually every
moment we generate data so my question
is about do you agree if something you
can measure then you can control it and
if
yes how to so let's let's have one
person answer that question excuse me I
have to follow follow my question key
point on the half last point so if you
I'm sorry we have two minutes and I'd
like one more question so you have one
you've asked a question um if you can
measure it you can control it any any
comments so I will take this second if
you no no one question for person
otherwise it's not fair
um go ahead yeah sorry oh so the panel
investors you you agree that doing um
Enterprise oriented Venture Capital vent
investment in China not wise twice but
here in the Silicon Valley in just the
tech Crown disrupt investors here they
call for entrepreneurs here to shift
their focus on Enterprise side um
projects and businesses and uh one of
the reason one reason that the
technological unemployment which is
which is is that uh the increasing pace
of automation has El limited jobs
permanently which kind of um contribute
to the weak Global demand um forces us
to focus on the Improvement on
productivity and uh this is can you get
to the question so the question is that
and so uh the question is that uh in
China so as what do you think about the
future of Art artificial intelligence
and the Robotics and in particular what
about what is the investment Prospect of
Robotics in China in terms of boosting
productivity to a new level which unlock
the um Chinese people's um
consumers account I'll answer the last
three questions in one statement we
always invest contrary to Conventional
wisdom full
stop all right on that well I I got to
sign that time is up so thank you for
the great panel and um I'm sure they'll
stick around for if any of you have
questions but I think everyone's waiting
for the next
one